>> Tucker: ALL OF A SUDDEN,
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS OF
VERMONT IS THE FRONTRUNNER IN
THE DEMOCRATIC RACE.
HE HAS THE BEST CHANCE OF
GETTING THE NOMINATION.
SO HOW SHOULD YOU FEEL ABOUT
THAT?
IF YOU’RE CONSERVATIVE, PROBABLY
HARD TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
I’M CAME OUT OF NOBODY.
NOBODY ON TV WARNED YOU WOULD
HAPPEN.
AND SANDERS IS NOT AS OFFENSIVE
AS SOMEONE LIKE ELIZABETH
WARREN.
UNLIKE WARREN, SANDERS IS
OBVIOUSLY SINCERE ABOUT WHAT HE
BELIEVES.
HE MEANS IT.
HE HAS THE RIGHT ENEMIES, TOO.
CNN APPEARS TO HATE BERNIE
SANDERS EVERY BIT AS MUCH AS
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT’S A PLUS.
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE ON THE LEFT,
SANDERS TALKS ABOUT ECONOMICS
RATHER THAN PUTIN AND NONBINARY
BATHROOMS.
IT’S REFRESHING TO HEAR SOMEONE
FOCUS ON THINGS THAT MATTER.
IT’S NOT LIKE HE’S GOING TO WIN
THE PRESIDENCY.
YOU KEEP HEARING ON BOTH SIDES
SAY THERE’S NO POSSIBILITY, NO
CHANCE IN THE WORLD THAT BERNIE
SANDERS WILL GET ELECTED
PRESIDENT IN NOVEMBER.
THAT SOUNDS RIGHT BASICALLY.
THE GUY CALLS HIMSELF A
SOCIALIST.
THIS IS AMERICA.
COME ON.
ARE WE SURE THAT THAT IS TRUE?
ASK YOURSELF THIS.
WHO WAS THE LAST CANDIDATE THAT
THEY TOLD YOU ON TELEVISION
COULD NEVER EVER WIN?
OH, YEAH.
THE CURRENT PRESIDENT.
SO IGNORE THE PEOPLE ON TV.
THEY’RE MORONS.
THEY LACK WISDOM, LACK
IMAGINATION.
ALMOST ALWAYS WRONG ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
OF COURSE, BERNIE SANDERS COULD
WIN THE GENERAL ELECTION.
A YEAR FROM NOW WE COULD BE IN
THE FIRST MONTHS OF A BERNIE
SANDERS ADMINISTRATION.
THIS WOULD BE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY WOULD IT
BE?
TONIGHT WE’RE BEGINNING A SERIES
ON BERNIE SANDERS’ AMERICA.
WE TAKE SANDERS SERIOUSLY.
WE THINK YOU SHOULD TAKE HIM
SERIOUSLY, TOO.
SO WE’RE STARTING TONIGHT WITH
SANDER’S VIEWS ON IMMIGRATION.
A TOPIC THAT AFFECTS THIS
COUNTRY ON EVERY LEVEL.
FOR DECADES, SANDERS HAD WHAT
WOULD BE CONSERVATIVE VIEWS ON
IMMIGRATION.
HE CARED ABOUT HIGHER WAGES FOR
WORKERS.
THAT WAS HIS ISSUE.
MASS IMMIGRATION LOWERS WAGES SO
HE WAS AGAINST IT.
IT’S THAT SIMPLE.
THEN SANDERS RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
HIS VIEWS CHANGED COMPLETELY.
NOW SANDERS IS AS RADICAL ON
IMMIGRATION AS ANYONE ELSE.
HE’S COME OUT ON ALL
DEPORTATIONS, ALL.
WATCH.
>> A MORATORIUM ON DEPORTATIONS
FOR THE 99% OF THE PEOPLE IS
NOTHING TO BE CYNICAL ABOUT.
I THINK THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
STEP FORWARD AND THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY WOULD BE
PROUD OF THAT.
>> Tucker: ENDING 99% OF
DEPORTATIONS TO PLEASE THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT THAT NUMBER
INCLUDES VIOLENT FELONS.
SANDERS WENT ON TO SAY THAT ONLY
IF AN ILLEGAL ALIEN COMMITS A
TERRIBLE CRIME, ONLY THEN
SANDERS "MIGHT" CONSIDER
DEPORTING THAT PERSON.
MIGHT.
SANDERS WOULDN’T HAVE TO CHANGE
ANY LAWS TO DO THIS.
HE COULD ORDER FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES TO STOP
DEPORTATIONS.
HE COULD DO THAT DAY ONE.
THAT’S HIS PLAN.
IMAGINE WHO THAT WOULD MEAN FOR
THIS COUNTRY?
FOREIGN NATIONALS COMMIT CRIMES
AND WE CAN’T SEND THEM HOME.
SANDERS WOULDN’T STOP THERE.
HE PLANS THE NEW WAY FORWARD
ACT.
IT’S DESIGNED TO PROTECT
CRIMINAL ALIENS.
THAT’S THE POINT OF IT.
SANDERS HAS PLEDGED TO END THE
BAN ON DEPORTED CRIMINALS
ENTERING THE UNITED STATES.
WHY IS THIS A GOOD IDEA?
HE PLEDGED TO ELIMINATE
EXPEDITED REMOVAL.
THAT ALLOWS OBVIOUS ILLEGALS TO
BE KICK OUT SWIFTLY.
HE PROMISED TO GIVE DISCRETION
TO JUDGES TO GIVE THE EDGE TO
ILLEGALS.
SANDERS VOWED TO END ALL
WORKPLACE IMMIGRATION RAIDS SO
BIG BUSINESS WILL BE ABLE TO
RELY ON ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT LABOR
WITH IMPUNITY.
SOMETHING THAT HE SPENT 30 YEARS
ATTACKING.
NOW HE’S FOR IT.
IT WILL BE EASY SINCE HE PLANS
TO ABOLISH ICE.
>> ON DAY ONE, WE WILL REPEAL
ALL OF TRUMP’S RACIST
IMMIGRATION EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
WE WILL END THE ICE RAIDS THAT
ARE TERRORIZING COMMUNITIES ALL
ACROSS AMERICA.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, BUSINESSES
WILL HAVE TO IMPORT MORE OF THAT
ILLEGAL EXPLOITED LABOR THAT
SANDERS IS FOR BECAUSE SANDER IS
PROMISING AMNESTY FOR ALL
ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THE COUNTRY.
MORE THAN 22 MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT IS A MOVE THAT WILL CHANGE
THE ELECTORAL PLANS PERMANENTLY
FOREVER.
THAT’S THE POINT, PEOPLE WILL
SAY.
BRINGING IN THE WORKERS WON’T BE
DIFFICULT.
HE PLANS TO ABOLISH THE BORDER
PATROL.
WHAT IS THIS?
THIS IS WHAT RADICAL OPEN
BORDERS POLICY LOOKS LIKE.
SANDERS IS ARGUING THAT EVERYONE
ON EARTH HAS THE EFFECTIVE RIGHT
TO COME TO THIS COUNTRY ANY TIME
AND RECEIVE THE BENEFITS OF
CITIZENSHIP.
SANDERS ADMINISTRATION, THOSE
BENEFITS WOULD INCLUDE BUT NOT
LIMITED TO FREE COLLEGE, FREE
HEALTHCARE AND FULL ELIGIBILITY
FOR FOOD STAMPS AND WELFARE.
WE’RE NOT MAKING THIS UP FOR
PARTISAN REASONS OR TO SLAM
BERNIE SANDERS BECAUSE IT LOOKS
LIKE HE’S GOING TO BE THE
NOMINEE.
THIS IS OUT THERE.
NOBODY IS MENTIONING IT.
IT’S ON TAPE.
SANDERS BRAGS ABOUT IT ALL.
WATCH.
>> I BELIEVE THAT HEALTHCARE IS
A HUMAN RIGHT.
>> SENATOR, WOULD YOU INCLUDE
THE 11 MILLION ILLEGAL --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT HEALTHCARE
BEING A HUMAN RIGHT, LAST TIME I
HEARD UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE ARE
HUMAN BEINGS AS WELL.
WE NEED THE BEST EDUCATED
POPULATION IN THE WORLD.
THAT MEANS WE’RE GOING TO MAKE
OUR PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TUITION-FREE AND
OPEN THAT TO THE UNDOCUMENTED AS
WELL.
>> Tucker: SO WHY ISN’T ANYBODY
TALKING ABOUT THIS?
PEOPLE ARE JUMPING UP AND DOWN
BECAUSE SANDERS PRAISED FIDEL
CASTRO.
SANDERS IS A SELF-DESCRIBED
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST.
IT’S BAD.
NO DOUBT.
BUT IS IT WORSE THAN WHAT HE
BELIEVES ON POLICY?
IT’S NOT CLOSE.
WHAT IS WAY WORSE THAN ANYTHING
HE SAID ABOUT FIDEL CASTRO?
HIS ARGUMENT THAT ANYONE ON THE
PLANET WHO SNEAKS IN TO THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD GET FREE
HEALTHCARE AND FREE COLLEGE
TUITION.
THAT’S THE CASE HE’S MAKING.
SO HERE’S THE OBVIOUS QUESTION.
WHAT WOULD THAT DO TO OUR
MEDICAL SYSTEM AND UNIVERSITIES?
HOW LONG BEFORE THEY COLLAPSED?
NOT LONG.
THESE ARE SYSTEM OF THE BEST
THINGS IN OUR COUNTRY, THIS IS
WHAT WE BRAG ABOUT.
GONE.
HOW WE WOULD PAY FOR IT?
WHY IS IT SUCH A GOOD IDEA?
WHY IS NO OTHER NATION DOING IT?
WHY HAS NO OTHER NATION EVER
DONE IT?
SANDERS HAS NO ANSWERS, THE MOST
BASIC QUESTIONS.
HE BECOMES ANGRY IF YOU ASK HIM.
HE DOESN’T CARE ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF HIS PLANS.
WHY?
THERE’S REALLY ONLY ONE POSSIBLE
ANSWER.
BECAUSE HE DOESN’T CARE ABOUT
THE UNITED STATES OR ITS FUTURE.
IT’S OBVIOUS THAT SANDERS HATES
THE COUNTRY HE SEEKS TO LEAD.
THERE’S NO OTHER EXPLANATION FOR
IT.
THAT IS A VERY DANGEROUS QUALITY
IN A PRESIDENT.
THE SHOW WILL CONTINUE TO BRING
YOU A SERIES ON WHAT LIFE WOULD
BE LIKE UNDER A BERNIE SANDERS
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE’S A LOT THERE.